Oscar season is in full swing yes all
about well this is all the award season
but the Oscars the big one that's the
big one and one of the films everybody's
talking about for Best Picture is the
la-la land
now if you haven't seen it la-la land is
a very sweet and surprisingly
traditional musical and I thought it was
nearly perfect except for one thing
there was one part of the movie that
bothered me there's this weird scene
where Ryan Gosling is singing on a pier
and he finds a fedora and this is the
actual scene in la-la land where he
finds the fedora he's found and he's
walking along the pier this is real
check it out
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
that I cannot make true okay now all
right
why did he just put a hat on a
stranger's head and then walk away okay
that's what I was wondering and then
even more bizarre just a little later on
in the film there's a whole subplot with
the couple later on and I didn't
understand this at oh this this bothers
me this part take it take a look and
they need just give you use that for
real good looking it's bad look that's
what it is
don't you know what a white boy puts a
hat on you that's a curse
that's just a tail our Grammys used to
tell us when we was kids just to scare
us ain't no such thing as no curse at
then you take it cuz I don't want it but
I look good in it too
[Music]
where did you go damn it
family do you see it
[Applause]
I killed you
[Music]
[Music]
why is nobody talking about that part of
the highway
why why didn't you go on longer
you